hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute so sein wie ihr
fuhr auf einem kanal auf dem spiel hoch
geladen was willi presse button heißt
ich würde nicht drücken und deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht wir machen das
heute mal wieder komm lass uns anfangen
und sieht mich jetzt gerade wieder einer
kleinen facetime eingeblendet und zwar
hans bis überhaupt warum es geht bei dem
spiel wohl gepresste button geht es
quasi darum dass wir einen knopf haben
und wenn wir den knopf drücken passiert
eine sache und als folge noch eine
andere sache oder wir drücken den knopf
nicht und alles bleibt quasi beim alten
und dann sieht man am ende wie viel
prozent den knopf wirklich gedrückt
haben und sich darauf eingestellt dass
die sachen die passieren würden und wie
viele den kopf quasi nicht gedrückt
haben
das heißt jetzt fangen wir an wenn wir
den knopf drücken ist es einerseits so
dass die person ja falls die in love und
you are no longer than chocolate okay
das ist schwierig wenn wir jetzt also
den knopf drücken ist es einerseits so
dass die person die wir über alles
lieben uns plötzlich auch liebt anna
setzte veganisch von aden essen da ich
allerdings schokolade eh nicht so sehr
markt und ich natürlich selbst den knopf
also wir gehen jetzt einfach mal und
drücken den knopf und wir sehen schon 77
haben den knopf gedrückt das heißt sie
sind in der mehrheit der übrigen das
spiel durchgespielt eurogate change to
restore live from scratch the new world
aber wir werden unser vorheriges leben
nur noch in leichten zügen in unserem in
unseren träumen wieder erleben was
niemals es geht jetzt hier bei darum
dass wir zwar wenn wir den knopf drücken
einerseits ein komplett neues leben
beginnen können also wir haben einen
neuen körper sind in einer neuen welt
ein quasi ein komplett neues leben
andererseits können wir uns an unser
vorheriges leben nur noch so ganz leicht
erinnern und das auch nur wenn wir
träumen also das heißt wir hätten alles
aus unserem vorherigen leben vergessen
deswegen will ich jetzt einfach mal
aufholen und wir sind in der minderheit
was findet ihr alle euer leben so
scheiße oder als ok damit würde ich
jetzt tatsächlich nicht gerechnet ob
besser geordnet weges rockstar rod
stewart okay das heißt wir sind der
größte rockstar der welt auf der anderen
seite sind wir allerdings leider taugt
das heißt beethoven besteht ja auch als
kommentar unter war sie genauso der
weihrauch taube hat trotzdem übelste
tracks rausgehauen wenn wir das mal so
sagen kann ich will ja eigentlich
ziemlich sicher bei und zwar will ich
auch gar kein rockstar sein also ich bin
definitiv auf ios debatten
das heißt wir sind wieder in der
mehrheit mit 60 prozent aber allgemein
bei solchen fragen die ja du bist der
größte profi der welt aber das will ich
gar nicht sein
also ich weiß nicht ich glaube das ist
nur noch stressig wenn man so übel
bekannt ist
hier hat man auf der einen seite
unendliche mengen an schokolade
allerdings schmeckt die komplett bitter
immer ich glaube jeder weiß dass bittere
schokolade eigentlich nicht so der
geschmack von den meisten menschen ist
wenn zufällig generiert ein story ein
und zwar habe ich mich mal mit einem
kollegen zu beginn meines studiums
getroffen und wir haben bei ihm halt ne
serie geguckt und dann holt schokolade
essen und er hat sie nur so übels
hochprozentige bittere schokolade und
hat irgendwie 80 prozent oder so und ich
sagte ja ok schokolade schmeckt
eigentlich immer ganz gut und wären dann
gegessen es war so eklat
das ist zwar weniger gesunde schokolade
dann gewesen und die ist mega gesunde
mir gehört die und witzig aber die
deswegen auf keinen fall die knock out
press the button
das heißt 62 wir sind wieder in der
mehrheit meine damen und herren internet
everywhere but you use or no fear
positiv in motions was das sind derzeit
echt sachen die kann man über die sie
beantworten
hier geht es darum das dürfte einen
seite immer und überall internet
connection haben allerdings auf der
anderen seite können wird nie wieder
etwas positives fühlen welcher kranke
süchtige mensch sagt da bitte ja ich
will den knopf drücken auf keinen fall
allein wir haben doch eh schon fast
überall internet aber trotzdem sagen
noch 30 also 16.700 7 40 leute dass sie
das machen würden
gott fertig los
[Musik]
was ist denn jetzt das wiki schulz ist
das einfach dieses break
wenn du so neue schuhe hat und die dann
an der hacke so ein bisschen aber hey
das ist doch also ich verstehe die frage
jetzt gerade nicht so ganz hat jetzt
jeder schuh denen ich kostenlos haben
will hat dieses kriegs oder oder jeder
schuh den ich allgemein besitzt das
heißt ich glaube ich wird daher auch
mein drücken weil so viele schuhe
brauche ich fress debatten und wo man
das ist hälfte hälfte julie benz samt in
den happy what do you remember the next
fand jedes but nobody remember that you
may day okay das heißt wir werden etwas
erfinden was in den nächsten 500 jahren
jeder benutzen wir jeder wird sich daran
erinnern dass das dieses ding halt
irgendwie vor 500 jahren erschaffen
wurde auf der anderen seite weiß keiner
dass wir es schaffen haben ist aber
eigentlich auch recht easy finde ich
will einfach definitiv den knopf drücken
weil dadurch das nichts erschaffen habe
und es jeder benutzen wird weil sich
dadurch habe ich ja kein nachteil und
ich will dich dass jeder so meinen namen
weiß das hat man gleich zu beginn schon
gemerkt als ich das mit dem rockstar
dinge auf 100 beantwortet habe also ja
auf jeden fall will ich den knopf
drücken ich meine tüte der menschheit
der lippen gefallen also wir sind in der
mehrheit auch mit 65
das ist ja relativ cool es gibt übrigens
einen coolen shop im internet unter
minister von de und zudem lukas shop
möchte ich auch noch mal ganz kurz eine
kleine sache sagen ich habe mir den luca
shop neu gelauncht am ersten dezember
und abbau werde auch ein paar tage
dauern und wir haben enorm viele neue
produkte darin recht ob das wisst ihr
mittlerweile wenn ihr meinen kanal und
den shops ein bisschen verfolgt ich
wollte euch nur mal sagen
in den ersten zwei wochen nach dem
release am ersten zwölf wurden 13.000
artikel von euch bestellt und das ist
das gab es noch nie
leute ihr seid einfach nur krank
deswegen weil ich halt einfacher
verdanken sagt ich mache jetzt schon
diese gewinnspiele reihe wo ich da ist
eine playstation alt von kamera und so
verlost unter allen abonnenten die quasi
main kanal abonniert haben
trotzdem leute ihr seid krank also ich
bin zwar immer dieses lukac ob ein und
sagt ja gar nicht soviel zu und so war
es einfach nur tiere also danke den ball
die can create brilliance world of the
movie guaranty trust of people but the
works of art will never be now to anyone
but you know it's okay das ist krass ihr
können auf der einen seite übels krasse
kunstwerke und gemälde erschaffen
allerdings auf der anderen seite wie die
nie jemand anderes sehen oder
kennenlernen außer wir selbst
aber ich war trotzdem der knopf drücken
ich meine es ist ja quasi so dass das
wie die teile hat trotzdem kreieren
können und haben keinen nachteil dadurch
wenn mir knopf nicht drücken also 62
wir sind wieder in der mehrheit travel
flut teil mit heinz but you can take
that s the future of shit is doch
trotzdem voll geil solche frage verstehe
ich halt immer natürlich die erste sache
ist ultra geil aber die zweite sache ist
doch quasi scheiß egal weil die erste
sache ja schon unserer geile natürlich
will ich darauf jahr drücken ich meine
es ist geil genug so dass wir genau sind
wenn ich euch sagen ihr könnt ab jetzt
zeitreisen aber ich könnte nichts
verändert aber dir noch sagen ja sogar
scheißegal ich kann zeitreise presse
button ich habe auch ich bin 80 prozent
in der mehrheit aber ich denke die frage
hat sich eigentlich schon selbst vorher
beantwortet youtube hole ich hab zu viel
meint breuer der schweiz auf der grauen
auf jeden fall
es ist immer noch besser als nicht
fliegen zu können ich drückt den knopf
und wir sehen mit 77% ich weiß nicht wer
da auch nein drückt leute diese 23
prozent wieder auf nein gedrückt haben
denkt ihr euch wirklich auch ich könnte
zwar fliegen aber näher will ich nicht
wenn es nicht mehr gehen als fünf meter
warum das hier ist jetzt krank und waren
wir auf der einen seite die übelste
power und wir könnten jeden besiegen der
sich irgendwie bei uns in den weg
stellen wir können die krassesten sachen
stämme fitnessstudio und so auf der
anderen seite können wir unsere kraft
nicht kontrolliert und jede person die
uns einfach nur umarmen
romani zurück die stirbt einfach weil
wir stark sind ich würde auf keinen fall
die knopf drücken alter es wird doch
einfach nur die seele mehrheit aber hey
jetzt wär doch einfach nur krank stelle
durchführung abend jemanden und er ist
einfach toll was die irre ab 530 release
ballade so you're exclusive ist mir
scheißegal 13 gaming serie
ich glaube die warten also die fenster
von warten schon so lange auf den
dritten teil und jetzt ist halt in der
frage so jahre haft läuft reis release
aber es ist eine exklusive und
videospiele sind ja immer so ein
bisschen kacke also ich würde sagen es
ist juckt mich nicht also von mir aus
aber naht ich weiß es nicht also
minderheit natürlich alles wieder so
eine 50 50 sache die vier ästhetik
happiness potter rest of your life live
wird mit f geschrieben ihr dumm trottel
auf der website but you have the world
of living auf der einen seite sind wir
die glücklichste person der welt auf der
anderen seite leben wir wieder letzte
keine ahnung was auf der straße und was
weiß ich also ich denke ich würde es
nicht drücken also minister schon
wohnkomfort und sondern so ein bisschen
gesundheit und so weiter in meinem leben
wichtiger als das jahr glücklich bin
sehr glücklich bin ich eigentlich
also ich klicke auf und wir sind in der
mehrheit ganz knapp mit 52 prozent meine
damen und herren aber das war's auch
schon die letzte frage die ich heute in
diesem video beantworten wollte wenn
euch dieses video idee gefallen hat
nicht das eventuell nochmal machen soll
dann lass mein finden leichter und wenn
ihr jetzt noch dran seid dann schreibt
einmal
button in die kommentare dann sehe ich
das beste ihr dran seid ihr buttons hier
findet ihr in zwei die eingeblendet wenn
ihr darauf könnt ihr kostenlos main
kanal abonnieren und verpassen quasi
kein video mehr und die nimmt
automatisch an einem gewinnspiel teil
ruhe derzeit eine kamera gewinnen können
und hier findet ihr ein anderes video
eingeblendet also zeigt dass auch auf
jeden fall mal ab ist auch mega reis yes